the cost of living crisis is getting
worse and it's very likely you've
noticed it in your own life but just how
long is it going to go on for and how
bad are things going to get
there are lots of different reasons that
things are getting more expensive
there's problems in the supply chains
hangovers from the covered 19 pandemic
and of course the war in ukraine but
rising bills now means that one in four
people have said they've skipped meals
and three and five have opted to turn
off their heating in order to save money
on the bills it's energy prices that
really underpin a lot of this cost of
living crisis
[Music]
in april the energy price cap rose by a
record 54
it means average household bills are now
around 2 000 pounds a year but things
are likely to get much worse when the
cap is reviewed again in october the
latest estimates are that bills could
rise to 2
600 pounds a year possibly even more
they're then expected to stay up at
around 2 300 pounds all the way through
to the start of 2024.
energy prices are one factor that
determine the overall rate of inflation
but rising costs of food goods and fuel
all contribute as well inflation has now
hit a new forty year high of nine
percent and forecasts expect that that
will rise to over ten percent by later
this year it means the steepest price
rises for four decades
and it'll be felt in all areas of life
one key concern is how wages just aren't
keeping up with that rate of inflation
in fact in the three months to march
wages fell in real terms by 1.2 percent
compared to the same period last year
that figure is a nine-year low a real
worst case scenario is if all this led
to what's called a wage price spiral
it's where employers raise wages for
workers to try and keep up with rising
costs while businesses put up the cost
of their products to match the rising
wages each pushing the other up into an
uncontrolled spiral and very high
inflation this happened in the 1970s and
it took years of deep economic pain to
bring inflation back down
another more likely worst case scenario
is a recession that's the official term
for when an economy shrinks if a country
is producing and selling fewer goods and
services if people struggling under the
cost of living crisis simply can't
afford to spend their money in the
economy then it will shrink the bank of
england has forecasted contraction later
this year council disposal income is
projected to fall by one and three
quarter percent in this 2022 which
apart from 2011 would be the largest
contraction since comparable records
began
in 1964. that would be seriously bad
news because a shrinking economy would
likely mean pay cuts job losses and a
whole lot more pain
[Music]
the uk is far from alone with these
concerns inflation and slow economic
growth are affecting lots of countries
around the world but there are places
like japan and canada that are faring
better making economic predictions at a
time like this is always a precarious
business but unfortunately things are
likely to get worse before they get
better and much of this pain will be
with us for at least a year
[Music]